hitting the government i
i have a note here because we have a
couple stories on cuba a couple stories
on iran
obviously china and i said it's
important to remember the people are not
the governments
of these countries and you talk we're
i'm sure we're going to talk about
what's
going on in iran we're talking about
cuba the people are the people the
government are not the people like we
talked about with general spalding that
what
six percent of china is part of the ccp
so
i hear you on that um so who's the
democrat that's do you as a government
control people
can get bigger do you think our
government represents us the people
right now
do you think our federal government this
administration
if you if you look at the approval
ratings for what's going on in congress
it's disastrously low and it's getting
lower
so no i think i think you know
don't i mean trump was the fascist trump
was the dictator but now we have people
saying they're going to go
door to door kick down your door yeah
drag you
out that's all rhetoric no no is that's
actually this is cuomo
yesterday andrew cuomo in new york state
yes that's your state that's your andrew
i don't know anything about that andrew
that's not happening you can google
actually pull that up are you
you haven't seen what cuomo said
yesterday
did you
okay let's see what cuomo has to say so
no it's an hour and 18 minutes you need
to find one that's like 30 seconds
this is the guy who was a leading
candidate for the next president
yeah so click on watch what he says yeah
there you go
we're talking about people that are
reading our text messages reading our
emails they're going to come to our
house and and
you know hit us with experimental
medication act happened right after 9 11
and there was overreach
obviously because it was shock and
discussion what happened in 911
and then just like we learned about with
taxes when pat did his tax episode
it's just temporary it's just temporary
and then what happens with the taxes pat
it keeps going and keeps going and then
i guess this is not
my issue why i keep picking on democrats
specifically especially in my family is
i know a lot of republicans who left the
republican party
and became libertarians or just became
independents or flat out never or
they're called rhinos now because they
said this patriot act is
we should never be in iran we should not
we should never be in afghanistan we
should never be in iraq
right off the bat they said this this
rumsfeld cheney stuff is nonsense
all right now he died recently yeah he
did like which you know weeks ago yeah
not that i'd dance on anybody's grade
but the world's a better place without
donald rumsfeld that's for sure
so and i don't even feel controversial
saying that we should have slingshot him
into the sun years ago
but the the cheney faction is now the
biden faction
and that's never admitted by democrats
it's never admitted that those guys
met right that's the establishment it's
the establishment man
so when we talk about that do they have
our best
look i i ascribe to something that
that's a pretty um
you like to talk about my extremist
views of of freedom and letting people
be
a volunteer society but i i do believe
we are tribal people
i believe we're naturally tribal that's
why i think it's so important for us to
promote
individualism and iron rand and to
the in the the beauty of the individual
because we are tribal we're naturally
tribal but that being said
we are always looking for a chief we're
always looking for a tribal chief i
ascribe to what's called the great man
theory it could be a woman it could be a
man
but we need more than ever in in my
lifetime
i cannot think of a time that we were
more devoid of leadership
that we did not have somebody that we
can look to and say you know what
this is somebody that knows well you had
your boy donald trump for four years
wait he's not my boy he's not donald
trump was not my boy
did i vote for donald trump i don't know
i'm asking him did i vote donald trump
2000 uh 2012.
all right here we go 2016. i voted for
donald trump in 2020
because this this walking talking zombie
that is
you know weakened at bernie's biden that
they keep propping up i mean he saw the
strings the others yeah i mean
how long until uh kumala harris finishes
off the job here man but i mean the
listen i didn't i didn't mind what trump
did i i really really
really really loathe the tactics the
democrats did
to to gain power in 2020. the fact that
you know just the lying the gaslighting
talking about the insurgency
after they burnt down the country for a
summer it's nonsensical
it's nonsensical all right and if we're
not able to live that's again i'm going
to say it for the third podcast in a row
that's why i love russell brand
the bill maher had another great one
this weekend that the left refuses to
ever admit progress
uh you know rogan like these guys who
are on the left
are saying enough enough already and
that's that's
it's got to come from there can't come
from the outside so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye